Wow edgy words edgy words between the
two feet while he did I mean there's a
respectful our own and sub-zero because
he did catch tag and I finish the combo
during a pollen Oh Alma breaker coming
out of Montana with the BMI like it oh
no now Zeke you're supposed to actually
hurt him that's the meter above shut up
how you're not here playing how about a
hammer I wanna be on your ass hammer oh
that was fail that's totally what haha
how many times you're gonna let him do
that well you gotta pee enemy by the way
for you are lady like a shadow dedicates
he's coming to everybody to Dan expert
haha you used to that I get more i get i
become even better expert when I'm not
playing see job I got a better expert
when I drink run try to press that and
then he gets a grand out of it Wow get
the grab on the little bit like I
planned that come on punch walks hashtag
[ __ ] walk oh ok howdy block can I try to
block that you go first walk to do that
you can't block throws knew how do you
break up yeah you can bring up yep hit
one of the buttons that you think I'm
gonna be hearing it's just that easy
it's just that easy hot-smoked I'll
bearden ice knock it off I wasn't even
call come on now oh oh here it comes oh
yes right now seek why did you pause it
while trying to do the thing oh yes
yeah yeah the reveal oh haha I feel like
that would be a really good whole
reality that would be really good at it
I'm gonna try it one of the other
variations
you